nous sommes en direct on va retrouver
lloyd austin qui est en train de
s'exprimer le secrétaire d'état à la
défense
les discussions étaient intéressantes
dans les couloirs et puis on a beaucoup
échangé entre les dirigeants toute la
journée alors encore une fois je
voudrais remercier tous les ministres et
et les ministères du ministre de la
défense et leur équipe en particulier
mon bon ami
le mystère et d'alphonse ukrainien
résonne cov et sa délégation ça fait
plaisir de le revoir
nous avons une compréhension
transparente et partager des défis qui
se posent à l'ukraine
je sais que nous sommes tous déterminés
à aider l'ukraine
aujourd'hui et à préparer les forces de
l'avenir on a travaillé en très peu de
temps ici et cela devrait faire une
grande différence sur le champ de
bataille de prise dans un bus qui l'a
dit on s'est rencontré à kiev le
dimanche
et tous les pays du dpi à travers du
monde se sont sentis responsables pour
aider l'ukraine répondre à ce défi je
voudrais remercier particulièrement une
grande décision de notre totalement le
ministère le ministre lambrecq vient
d'annoncer aujourd'hui que l'allemagne
enverra en ukraine 50
systèmes de décès à tchita
hier le gouvernement britannique a
déclaré qu'il fournirait à l'ukraine des
capacités de déchets supplémentaires et
aujourd'hui le canada a annoncé qu'il
enverra à l'ukraine
huit
véhicules de cet ordre donc ce sont les
progrès importants on voit les progrès
tous les jours et je remercie tous les
pays qui ont répondu à ces exigences
n'ont pas de temps à perdre
briefing aujourd'hui a montré pourquoi
les semaines à venir seront si
fondamental qu ils craignent donc il
faut aller au rythme de la guerre je
sais que tous les dirigeants
réunis ici aujourd'hui son réseau n'est
plus que jamais à soutenir l'ukraine
dans sa lutte contre l'agression russe
et contre les exactions russes je sais
est que nous sommes tous résolus à faire
davantage pour mieux coordonner nos
efforts
j'ai été particulièrement fier
d'entendre le général walter nous dire
qu'il était déterminé à utiliser
davantage les mécanismes de coordination
de l'uss cole us comme et pour s'assurer
de pouvoir continuer à progresser nous
allons veut prolonger ce forum de
discussion et nous annoncerons sans
doute que il s'agira d'un groupe de
contact mensuel sur les forces d'auto
défense ukrainienne ce conte groupe de
contact permettra de montrer la bonne
volonté de chacun malgré nos différences
et pour coordonner une autre aide et se
concentrer sur la lutte aujourd'hui et
les luttes à venir ces réunions
mensuelles pourront être en direct
ouverte virtuel et vont étoffer la
transparence l'intégration et le
dialogue que l'on a constaté aujourd'hui
je voudrais souligner autre chose de
très important
on a eu une cession importante
aujourd'hui sur le soutien à long terme
pour les défense ukrainienne y compris
que faut-il pour notre industrie de la
défense que faut-il faire ça veut dire
qu'il faut répondre à l'énorme demande
de démission de munitions et de
plateformes techniques que l'on constate
nous sommes très résolus à soutenir
l'ukraine et nous devons répondre dans
l'eau propre demande ainsi qu'aux
demandes aux exigences de nos alliés ça
signifie aussi que nous allons redoubler
d'efforts pour renforcer
les
sue stabilité craignant pour là le long
terme nous aurons des discussions au
sein du groupe de contact est ailleurs
pour trouver la bonne formule encore une
fois j'aurais remercier tous les pays
qui sont se sont solidarisés aujourd'hui
qui ont fait un travail essentiel et qui
ont lancé un signal important nous
allons poursuivre ses progrès
d'aujourd'hui continuer de rassembler
ces bonnes volontés pour aider l'ukraine
à bien se défendre nous allons continuer
de travailler de manière transparente et
dans l'urgence avec nos alliés nous
allons continuer de pousser à la roue ou
soutenir et rendent compte renforcer les
militaires ukrainien pour les batailles
à venir donc nous dès aujourd'hui nous
nous sentons renforcés tout comme le
crem merci et je suis prêt à répondre
aux questions
première question silvino tome afp
merci
monsieur secrétaire
j'ai deux questions
nous avons d'avis
a renforcé ses mesures de sécurité après
une série d'explosions en transe dyens
tri
pensez vous qu'il ya un risque que le
conflit des barres de moldavie deuxième
question
après cette grande réunion
entre les alliés et l'ukraine
n'est de paquets
que
poutine s'agite
et menace encore une fois d'utiliser
l'armé nucléaire
en ce qui concerne en ce qui concerne
plutôt les répercussions sur la malle de
vie étant donné ces rapports
d'explosions et de violences nous
examinons encore quelles sont les causes
de cet état chose nous sommes encore en
train de l'examiner ce qui s'est passé
ne savons pas encore mais nous allons
nous focaliser là-dessus
et il ne faudrait pas que ça déborde en
effet ce conflit mais encore une fois il
est important de s'assurer que l'on
fasse tout ce qu'on peut faire pour
s'assurer que le crel réussissent et
c'est la meilleure manière de traiter
ces problèmes deuxième question déjà
menace par poutine de l'armé nucléaire
du type d'armes nucléaires vous avez
entendu dire un certain nombre de fois
que ce genre de discours est très
dangereux et ne fait pas français les
choses personne ne souhaite une guerre
nucléaire une guerre une guerre qui
ferait perdre tous les participants donc
battre du tambour faire en temps des
bruits de bottes de toute évidence sert
pas à grand chose est ce nous n'allons
pas y participer question suivante
suzanne galles woerth 2ed
fdf sans micro
foucault maître militaire du
gouvernement allemand pensez vous que la
livraison de blindés et suffisante de la
part des allemands
vous voulez parler des cheetahs d'accord
je veux dire
et je l' ai déjà dit auparavant quand je
fais une en allemagne je considère
l'allemagne comme étant un grand ami et
un allié
j'ai servi
en allemagne j'ai travaillé pour les
forces militaires allemands disent a
toujours été un grand plaisir de
travailler avec nos partenaires
allemands
il est important de constater que
l'allemagne a annoncé qu'elle allait
fournir 50 system cheetah et ces
systèmes permettront à l'ukraine de
faire des choses alors qu'est ce que
l'allemagne peut tout peut faire
d'autres à l'avenir encore une fois
c'est le rap à hilard appartient de
décider il appartient aux dirigeants
allemands de le faire je ne peux pas me
lancer la spéculation je considère qu'à
partir de tout ce que j'ai vu quand j'ai
parlé avec le ministre de défense
quand j'ai vu qu'elle voulait vraiment
s'assurer de faire tout ce qui était en
son pouvoir pour faire avancer les
choses et travailler avec les alliés les
partenaires je crois que elle va trouver
des moyens d'être pertinente utile et de
fournir de bonnes capacités aux
ukrainiens dans leur lutte
j'ai un respect new york times
les terres vous avez dit hier que l'un
des objectifs des états unis en ukraine
était d'affaiblir la russie pouvez-vous
expliciter ce que cela signifie qu'est
ce que vous voulez
affaiblir et comment allez vous mesurez
votre réussite
je crois qu'on a été assez clair
d'emblée
nous voulons faire en sorte que ce soit
plus difficile pour la russie de menacer
ses alliés et qu'ils soient moins
capables de le faire alors qu'est ce
qu'on a vu se produire au cours de ces
soixante deux jours de conflit entre la
russie et l'ukraine
la russie
du point de vue de ses son armée son
armée a été très affecté il ya pas mal
de victimes ils ont perdu beaucoup
d'équipement aussi ils ont utilisé
beaucoup de munitions ils ont perdu
beaucoup de combattants
ils sont donc très affecté et sont moins
forts qu'ils étaient au départ et ce
sera difficile pour eux de remplacer
certaines de ses capacités à l'avenir
étant donné les sanctions et les
restrictions commerciales qui ont été
apposées donc nous voudrions nous
assurer encore une fois qu'il n'est pas
le même type de capacité
pour persécuter leurs voisins ce qu'on
l'avait constaté au début de la guerre
question suivante
ousmane regard de ard
bonjour
comment peut-on bâtir une écrit une
ukraine sur
est-ce que l'ukraine pourrait adhérer à
l'otan
encore une fois ça sera une décision que
les ukrainiens devront prendre et l'otan
de reprendre
mais je crois que nous serons toujours
respecté du principe d'ouvrir de garder
la porte ouverte je voudrais pas
supputer ce qu'il peut se passer mais je
crois
qu'à l'avenir
il y a des possibilités
et si cette possibilité d'adhérer existe
l'ukraine cherchera encore à adhérer à
l'otan dans une fois
c'est un petit peu nous encore et ça ne
servirait pas à grand-chose de spéculer
actuellement que je crois que la
première étape la première chose à faire
c'est de terminer ce conflit
ce qu'il faut pour mettre un terme à ce
conflit c'est que monsieur poutine
prenne la décision de mettre un terme
c'est lui qui l'a commencé sans aucune
raison et
c'est à lui qu'est la part te
appartiendra de décider de une
désescalade et de négocier et nous nous
sommes tous pour cette solution la
dernière question
ou vers des chaînes tv tu t'es b2b mac
mais si le secrétaire
le ministre des affaires étrangères
russe a déclaré qu'il y avait un risque
d'une troisième guerre mondiale et qu'un
risque d'utilisation des armes
nucléaires ne craignez-vous pas que ce
conflit
échappent au contrôle de tous et
débouche sur une confrontation nucléaire
nous allons faire tout ce qui est en
notre possible
et les graines aussi va faire la même
chose pour
empêcher cette escalade la communauté
internationale est d'accord avec nous
mais encore une fois je crois que tout
les fanfaronnades sur l'éventualité
d'une utilisation de l'armé nucléaire
est très dangereuse et ne sert à rien
personne est en faveur d'une guerre
nucléaire que quelque soit le point
gagné
nous agissons et nous assurerons de
garder un équilibre et d'adopter la
bonne démarche donc
il ya toujours un risque de que
certaines choses arrivent mais encore
une fois je crois que ça ne sert à rien
c'est même dangereux
de faire entendre des bruits de bottes
et de se lancer des spéculations sur
l'utilisation d'armes nucléaires merci
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on avait prévu
pour cette conf presse de conférences
vous remercie